here's the real State of the Union over
the past two years undebiden millions
and millions of illegal aliens from 160
different countries have stormed across
our Southern border drug cartels are now
raking in billions of dollars from
smuggling poison to kill our people and
to kill our children
Savage Killers rapists and violent
criminals are being released from jail
to continue their crime wave and unto
Biden the murder rate has reached the
highest
in the history of our country
Biden and the radical Democrats have
wasted trillions of dollars and caused
the worst inflation in half a century
real wages are down 21 months in a row
gas prices have sort and are now going
up much higher than even before and the
typical American family is paying 2 200
in increased energy and food costs each
year Joe Biden's weaponized justice
department and I'm a victim of it is
persecuting his political opponents his
administration is Waging War and Free
Speech they're trying to indoctrinate
and mutilate our children he's leading
us to the brink of World War III and on
top of all of that he's the most corrupt
president in American history and it's
not even close but the good news is we
are going to reverse every single crisis
Calamity and disaster that Joe Biden has
created I am running for president to
end the destruction of our country and
to complete the unfinished business of
making America great again we will make
our country better than ever before and
we will always put America first thank
you okay so so millions of immigrants
yeah 160 different countries he's gonna
that's his campaign he just gave you his
pleasure right there yeah signature
issue beautiful yeah exactly absolutely
Savages and rapists are being released
from prison Sanctuary cities or you know
border find grade three real wages are
down 21 months in a row economy to
strength typical American Family paying
twenty two hundred dollars in increased
energy and food costs it's felt Middle
America he's talking to low and middle
income families the average family is
spending Joe Biden's weaponized justice
department
perfect on what is going on with that
and now it's backfiring on Biden he's
going to play that no problem he's uh
turning us into potentially world war
three leading us into World War Three
that is a very very uh it could be a
valid issue that he's bringing up he's
the most corrupt president ever we don't
know what's going to happen now with
Kevin McCarthy and them leading the
house the investigation that you're
going to see every day hunter or
somebody's out there being talked about
all this stuff they're gonna have to
address that and then he came back and
said I'm going to come back we're going
to make put America first again so uh
you know if you only watch the State of
the Union you're Blown Away by you know
you're like okay this was a decent
speech if you watch it from Trump's side
you see all the flaws if you watch it
from Sarah Huckabee's side you see the
flaws if you watch it from CNN side they
were ecstatic on how great of a job he
did so it all depends on who's watching
it right so so but here's the point up
that when we're seeing
this taking place with the uh the State
of the Union given being given and Trump
given what message he just gave at what
point
do you sit there and say okay because
Trump hasn't yet turned on the throttle
on really going campaigning this isn't
Trump campaigning yet
with the timing of when the state of the
union is first week of February okay and
on Election time we got what right now
22 months 21 months whatever the
timeline is
when do you see historically where all
of a sudden this Full Throttle Trump's
going 100 offensive when does that
happen first of all I think his uh
announcement of candidacy was more of a
marker than it was the beginning of a
campaign he was letting everybody in his
own party and in the other party no I'm
definitely running you don't need to
speculate about it secondarily
um while he is raising money uh and
between the time he announced uh and the
end of the filing period he raised 9.5
million dollars now to me that's a lot
of money people say oh he underperformed
well he's no overhead because he's not
out doing rallies the rallies by the way
are a half million dollars a piece a
half million dollars so uh you know he
is he's he has a very lean staff uh he
is doing events like he did in New
Hampshire and South Carolina which keeps
his his campaigns expenses down he's not
recognize those now need to be paid for
by his by his re-election campaign uh
and uh here's where I think he is making
an error and hopefully he will change
his mind uh he's been putting out some
very good issue oriented videos I
thought that was a very good video uh
but he needs to put them on Twitter
it is a mistake to just continue to to
post uh solely uh at true social first
of all I love to social but it is by
definition uh you're talking to your
base 100 it is a great place to talk to
people not all of whom but most of whom
agree with you but in terms of talking
to everybody
your supporters uh and your opponents
and those in the middle
um I don't think Twitter can be beat uh
he has 87 million followers on Twitter
he has a little over three million uh
followers I think on true social I could
be a little off on that uh let's say
that a substantial number of the people
following me on Twitter are Bots
let's say it's 50 which I don't think it
is yeah well that means he has 42
million people I mean that's still an
enormous number of Pizza so I'm hopeful
that he will begin posting this this uh
content this video content particularly
he doesn't have to use Twitter you know
for his for his sniping yeah which he
loves to do of course uh which is just
kind of part of his political persona
but I do think he needs to occasionally
occasionally go back on Twitter is there
is there any is he contractually binded
to troop social or he's not okay he's
not so do you guys think this is like a
tactical move where he's just waiting
he's biting his time to actually like
just hit it Like Pat was saying to go
full throttle and then it all comes out
or he's or he's just like does he still
have like a sour taste in his mouth from
the way he was treated and and and
banned uh the most predictable thing
about Donald Trump is that he's
completely unpredictable so it's hard
it's not I love it and it's not always
easy to understand exactly why he he's
doing what he's doing but in all cases
he's doing it with some purpose I do
think he understands that the very first
time he goes back to Twitter that's a
huge story that's an enormous story and
therefore when he goes there he should
go there to say something of substance
these videos are are really quite good
but they're not getting the kind of
residence I think they they could get if
he posted occasionally on Twitter can we
can we do uh uh uh what do you call it
can we put a poll and ask how many
people today on this live are actually
on Truth social I'd be curious to know
how many people are on truth so if you
have to guess what would you say Pat
from the people in the chat less than
five percent are on truth so I was I was
gonna say less than five and I think
that's a high number to to be on true
social I don't think that many people
are on Truth social so but here's the
question though
um you only get to do your first tweet
once right first you're coming back to
it you only get to do it once and I
believe it's going to end up being the
most like tweet in the history of
Twitter and the most retweeted tweet on
the in the history of Twitter until it's
like a terrible waste of a first
opportunity if it's like a video if it's
something that's really solid it'll be
record-breaking you know 100 200 300
million views is what the video is going
to get I believe that
do you think knowing him he's hanging
tight to make sure that the first one is
not only perfectly timed to maximize the
effort to not just waste it right now
because it's too early to drop Twitter
well put it this way I agree with your
analysis that the first time he does it
will be a mega story that's like times
five rallies right right in terms of
reach uh and he does have a good sense
of timing so yeah I think he I think
he's going to use it both when he has
something very important to say and also
when there is more Focus right now in
our party he's the only candidate
running the field is not has not been
has not been filled uh there's a lot of
people
did she formally announce her did she
announced that she's going to announce
I'm not sure but she made her intention
right you know so I think it'd be fair
to to count her as a candidate I guess
um but I do think it is a it's an asset
that he will use at the right time to go
back to another point you made and I
think this is an absolute kid which is
two billion dollars more for Ukraine in
this speech two billion I mean it is it
is true that particularly because of U.S
based coverage of the war most Americans
support Ukraine uh most Americans are
opposed to Putin uh and Russia but at
some point we have 370 000 homeless
veterans in this country uh and uh in
the end I think it'll be up to the FED
as to whether we have a recession or not
it is entirely possible Republicans more
than all voters recognize the
correlation between massive spending and
inflation and inflation is uh the number
one
along with immigration I think the
number one and number two problem for
this Administration so uh I believe the
war not only am I worried about us kind
of stumbling into World War Three
um but I also think that it's very
conceivable that like the Vietnam War
like the Korean War the war could become
very unpopular over time the longer the
war goes uh the more unpopular will
become because of the cost uh and also
the softer our economy is the more the
resentment that we are seeming to be
just running the printing presses and
sending this money uh to Ukraine
so um I do think Trump's greatest single
potential opportunity
uh is to run as the peace candidate as
Eisenhower said I will end the war in
Korea Nixon said I will end the war in
Vietnam
given the Middle Eastern peace deal
which Trump got done which no one
thought possible given the fact that it
was Trump who turned off the Russian
Pipeline uh and Trump who gave the
offensive weapons to the ukrainians that
Obama would not give them given Trump's
diplomatic success success in North
Korea where he at least got the Mad ban
to to stop his nuclear weapons
development testing which is now
restarted under Joe Biden I mean I think
he has credibility as a deal maker as a
negotiator and I think he appealed to
that anti-interventionist
streak in America and particularly the
Republican party in 2016 and I think uh
I think he will do so again
were you going to say yeah so I think
just to pick you up of what Roger was
saying in terms of Ukraine I definitely
think that U.S has passed the line that
Putin kind of Drew in the sand to begin
with of supporting Ukraine and
specifically through military equipment
through the taxes that they've been
sending and stuff like that so if Putin
really wanted to I think that he has
Justified a reason on his end uh to
really launch full out further war on
that end but my concern would definitely
be more on the uh on the opposite side
of China versus uh Russia really
starting something that we'd kind of
accidentally stumble into Roger at the
end of the day because I'm as a veteran
too just like Pat too when we're giving
all this money and we're helping we're
you know the the ACT to me is everybody
we're the flag and UK we're sending all
these billions what is the end what are
we in it for that's an excellent
question because we signed a treaty in
1994 between Ronald Reagan and leader uh
Gorbachev in which we agreed not to push
Ukraine into NATO which means really not
to mount offensive Western Finance
missiles on the ground in Russia
we do have bioweapons Labs there the
administration stumbled and admitted it
then they tried to pull it back uh and
if you say well we're there to support
democracy
zielinski has arrested everybody ran
against him in the last election he's
outlawed all the other parties he closes
down newspapers he closed down TV
stations he closes down radio stations
he arrests journalists he just closed
down the largest church in the country
so this is it's not about democracy uh
and I think we have been provocative now
people watch that say oh there you go
Roger Stone is a Putin apologist he
loves Putin he's a russophile no I I had
family members mowed down by Russian
tanks in Budapest in 1956. I have no use
for Putin he's a thug I have no use for
their for their system uh but I do this
is most certainly not about democracy uh
and uh I really fear that we could
stumble into World War Three okay so if
you enjoyed this clip you want to see
another one click here to watch another
clip and if you want to take advantage
the latest gold Signature Series
products that just came out we have a
bunch of new merch that's out this is a
color changing mug when you drink coffee
that lion turns into a real line and
then we have hoodies with Valium and
gold on it the gold Signature Series hat
shirts I'm an entrepreneur anyways we
have a lot of items they're selling out
if you want to take advantage the gold
Signature Series click here place your
order Sports your right taming gear and
tag us with the hashtag valuetainment
[Music]